Hello and welcome the fire of learning the future.
No one can truly predict what is to come,
but we can make some educated guesses and today that's what we're going to do
and looking at what Europe might look like in the year 2025 keep in mind,
as always,
I keep my political,
religious and social views out of my videos.
These predictions are what might happen based off analysis of what's going on
now,
not necessarily what I want or do not want to happen now.
Then let's get to it.
First up,
let's look at potential border changes.
If you see my video,
the 25 independence movements of Europe,
you know about the many regions of Europe containing calls for independence.
Such calls are perhaps the loudest and the UK,
Spain and Italy where Scotland may again pursue independence from the UK along
with Catalonia and the Basque regions.
Pursuits of separation from Spain,
Italy,
maybe facing complete fragmentation as not only does Benito in the northeast of
the country desire independence,
but many in the north and south favor separating from each other and even many
on the island of Sardinia.
Find the idea of separation favorable all the while in the east,
some regions are essentially functioning independently already such as northern
Cyprus,
Transnistria,
and Kosovo.
However,
the independence and right to sovereignty of each of these places remains hotly
debated.
It's possible that in 2025 each of these nations may be independent or each of
them may be absorbed and their independence movement snuffed out as far as
border tensions between already independent nations go.
The most tense in Europe is Ukraine and Russia as the bait over Crimea and
eastern Ukraine.
In 2014 following a Crimean referendum to join Russia,
Russia annex the Crimean Peninsula.
While it remains under Russian control,
many nations in the international community do not recognize it and demand
Russia return it.
The future of Crimea as well as the heavily Pro-russian Donbass region of
Ukraine remains uncertain,
but it's possible Russia might retain a territory in the future and now for the
demographics of Europe,
you have likely heard frequently of the threats of overpopulation,
which our planet is facing.
However,
in Europe,
the population is actually facing natural decline from low fertility rates.
As you can see on this map,
the highest birth rates are in France at 1.96 children per mother and the lowest
is in Bosnia at 1.28 the fertility rate and necessary to replace a population in
developed nations is about two children per mother.
Just to keep in mind,
the populations of Europe,
however,
are actually increasing because of immigration primarily from Africa and the
Middle East.
It's likely that up to 6.3% of the population of the European Union was born
somewhere outside of it.
Debate rages heavily as to whether or not immigration is beneficial or harmful
to Europe,
but it's likely that though there will be a mix of responses to the issue,
the native born population will continue to decline and the foreign born
population will continue to rise throughout the year 2025 religion,
while three fourths of Europe remains Christian.
If current trends continue,
there will be a rise in Erie,
religiosity,
agnosticism and atheism.
As of today,
the Czech Republic,
Sweden,
France,
and the Netherlands are home to the highest number of atheists and the continent
comprising one third of these nations with higher numbers,
still believing in some sort of God or spiritual forests,
but turning away from Christianity and on top of that many Christians on the
continent state that religion is not greatly important to their daily lives.
Some correlate this rise with a breakdown of tradition and morality,
others with a rise and scientific understanding.
Likewise,
there is the bait as to whether or not this is a positive or negative change.
The largest growing religion in Europe,
however,
correlating with the rise in immigration is Islam,
where perhaps 6% of the population or 44 million people are Islamic and this
trend will likely continue and increase into 2025 the European Union with the UK
voting to leave the European Union in 2019 Brexit may encourage other nations to
leave as well.
Dislike of the EU seems to be the strongest in nations like Hungary,
Latvia,
Greece,
France,
and Spain.
Vote trouble may lie ahead for the EU.
Reforms may encourage some members to stay and even other nonmembers to join
such as many of the nations in the Balkans and Turkey.
What the EU will look like in 2025 remains uncertain.
Science and technology there will likely continue to be a considerable increase
in fields like health and medicine,
alternative energy and computers and robotics and transportation and years to
come.
Diseases like dementia type one diabetes,
AIDS and cancer may decline with new forms of treatment and understanding about
these diseases.
Solar and wind power will likely become more prevalent.
As many European nations have already made goals to implement these energy
sources to combat climate change.
With Germany,
lean away in both solar and wind power on the continent,
electric and automated cars will likely begin to become more commonplace.
With companies like Tesla being responsible for such technology already being on
the road,
the use of cash will life.
You start to give way to electronic forms of payment.
Artificial intelligence will likely become more intelligent,
continuing on a path toward equaling our own intelligence and much,
much more.
Though,
as I said,
these predictions are educated guesses.
No one for sure knows what has to come,
and ultimately the future depends on our decisions and the present.
Is there anything else you expect Europe to see by the year 2025 let me know in
the comments section below.
For more videos like this and videos on many other subjects from terraforming to
history to dreams,
to philosophy,
I'd invite you to check out fire of learning and subscribe.
Thank you for watching.